how's ago Braz - beer thank you we're
gonna play Gabi I try to do a gang sign
we're getting pretty fun yes you are so
excited stop jiggling your butt I meant
that was not you well yay I'm the blue
one I'm doing one okay good I don't hug
me don't help me bro hey bro bro bro
this is not your turf bro bro bro you
dance so I catch me over here oh he
walks too light but you got a point for
that
can't we do the Dirty Dancing moon I'm
and the time on my lap Oh bro Oh bro Oh
bro ha ha and I owe it all to the bro
all right
have to jump yay I can't jump at all
don't hug me from such a sexual gay oh
yeah that's the only thing you like a
good booty so can you jump cuz I can I
can already tell
ah dieter well I did something what are
you doing
it's memo or neck but you know when I
hug yeah I wanted to thank ya smell mom
hey yeah wedding and wedding come
winning is that what he's all about
no way this is a tutorial just to learn
the control thank you it's a fighting
game it's a fighting game get over II
don't hug me don't hump me oh you stay
down belly flop belly flop
no no no I'm not yet my flap oh oh what
are you doing let me go let me go let me
go
out you can you touch my junk I'm great
I what is happening what is happening
you lucky nope into the game I know what
okay things were specified thank you
very very much
glad we know that now
punch lead left and right are you doing
I'm stuck here sir sad hey bro don't be
soon hmm
I don't meet you supposed to help you
can also grab it I think okay so you
grab it with there also dead okay bro
bro bro you can furnish whatever bro how
do you grab it and same as you punch you
see you
yo good job I knew your anus you yeah
that's good time
oh thanks appreciate it my nip you got
my never Hey
I'm sensitive hey sabe
stop stop bra bra bra no bruh bruh bruh
bruh Mariah so help my leg really like
you put thank you go hey no you cannot
have okay come on okay
Oh go up students do much calories climb
it's me how do you all like that I'm
having your whole day in X no no no no
no no no no no why all right this is
gonna become painful for them to watch
oh good job yeah yeah okay careful
careful now all right let me let me show
you how it's done okay
Oh God like one move and he goes to town
give me okay I got it
no I'm not even blinking hey some King
me there you go all right I'm going
later yes
easy you can do it hold them down hold
both both of them down can't watch never
aim it I think okay don't don't know
what are you doing there okay I'm
grabbing it I'm gonna really go oh okay
I didn't I swear it's just a game it's
just a game
yeah do they say that when Titanic yeah
exactly
don't grab my throat I'm not a growl
wait I thought I mistook my leg for a
penis can't look like it's nothing
happens in life - got it
yes okay you got a good grip on it yes
yes are you okay while grabbing lift
hell objects so you grab one and then
you hold Y and then I'm trying to figure
out the game here you are an embryo all
right you got a many just give this B
okay well I'll go okay dropping it and
you hold Y
Thanks it's me you deadhead
yeah I come over here and we can dance
okay
yes ymc why and what are you doing you
know what let's have a battle to the
death
MC come here good be my bro all right we
did it
sorry yo yo sup hey guys no are we
supposed to just throw each other down
yes the gang wars blue versus red Oh bro
no bro
no I did it because I'm blue I'm a diva
man Javid I'm a diva but Mainichi Oh
what why your self but I want to make
the jump
oh it's longer duck am i controlling it
hang on I'm gonna say I coming for you
my see ya oh we have the job we have to
jump
well we have to jump okay you know I'm
gonna gem you see step every Marie
killed me
let's jump together yeah see your last
boss know that say your last prayer are
you came back to life
never I'll never let you but go say you
love me I'm stuck actually you're but
I'm stuck in between I'm free I'm free
no God Oh God
yeah Breaking Bad Breaking Bad fine how
are we break no I don't mean to I don't
mean to help your first get run over is
awesome no I'll do that don't know be
yeah don't know sexy we don't do that
help hey could I get a hand foot wow I
don't you have to try country roads
what are you wide let go what you give a
[ __ ] huh hey bro you think of a [ __ ] huh
you wanted you want to mess with this
you up from them okay I'm from there a
belly flop belly fun hey what are you
doing
coming coming really flip oh you're at
Stata oh I broke my eyebrow my
everything you want to fight demand real
money for a pie I'm deer down I'm down
I'm down hey do you don't hit blood it's
you you don't want is him now I got you
now no you're all mine okay well they
never get I'm gonna do my alley
yeah I'm gonna throw you out come here
come here come on I just want to hug you
just wanna hug you please let me let me
hug you tonight anything arrey arrey
cheerleading
oh yeah this is gonna be so many wrong
things this is you know I bring it bring
it bring it
hmm yeah never did it ever dear I'm from
Sweden mother effer
yep get your ass no so fast and you let
me go I'm not trying to be perverted
it's this DJ right swing Hey look out my
face
Froggy's my car around please I'm gonna
drag you so hard your Bernie's gonna
come out of you what yeah what did you
say about my brain brah
oh no you did
oh yes yes
Swedish power the best power you want to
dance
all righty you know I didn't you say
that let's dance yes damn to have a good
time I love dancing oh wow
the weather is mmm oh thank you gonna
say look at my boobs but II don't have
one
oh damn that jump though Jesus J's no
all right so don't I don't think you
want to follow that indeed what I got
him instead I'm stuck over here
yes yes yeah yeah oh yeah of course you
did it okay all right I'm gonna leave
you there I want to show you around
today I want to show you around the
place suppress him
have a good time down Yaya how did that
happen
all right on the first alright thank you
oh are you doing you're having me from
behind a lab on your - oh come on yeah
just like take ten you do it let's do
the Titanic oh my hands doo doo doo doo
you know what let's say let's not
weighted it because it's over there
sever they stay where they if I jump oh
and then and then no in the belly okay
okay it's my time to try me under my
bill but yeah thank you a nice time
right now
it's Richard in the background what he's
like
I love it I love it I love it
belly flop then our box is my only
weakness okay
you're glad you got to have me at it we
gotta have me a mess yeah I'm trying let
me go let me go let me go I need to be a
box need to be backs
don't stop me from being Who I am okay
what are you yeah we what you Bernard to
what you Craig Hey Oh are we holding
hands it's a romantic I'm not worried at
all and as long as I can do it can we
enter here know what why I could have
entered the other doors can I come in
please let me be but brutal yeah you
come out ahead
that's all right let me go I'm gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of you oh oh oh I'm
finding everything at everyone Fido
everyone anytime oh oh oh you want to go
up face yeah I want to go what do you
weigh ah yeah yeah you better come back
on no okay oh god I'm so fat why did I
eat so many times I love tacos
come on man just love tacos what are you
doing breaking my turf
come on bring it Brittany I'm here
you lucky one yeah I wanna fight huh
yeah what a fine dude yeah just a yeah
why sure I go to camp
yeah with my rank of town seeing well I
say sorry I'm saying beautiful that yeah
yeah I'm sorry about earlier
yeah I got your head no face please I'll
do anything I'll even cook for you no
more tacos actuary
no my jacket no Chow God we have to edit
here but if you enjoy watching leave a
like and let me let us know if you want
more why and we'll see you and next
video you want eating the but that's not
that that is the different channel God
Bailey breakfast not together okay
breakfast I was with a house throw face
in Dubai